These words may make you think of a thick
fluid—milked from the fangs of a dangerous
snake.
But the latest venom science is turning to
new sources of venom: centipedes, assassin
bugs, and stealthy cone snails.
With the rise of tools that let scientists
explore all the proteins, peptides, and small
molecules that make up venom,
scientists have been able to deconstruct the
potent toxic cocktails made by the world’s
tiniest mixologists.
Some of those include rare animals that aren’t
easy to raise in the lab.
Most venomous animals aren’t so rare.
There are more than 220,000 species that brew
up
their own toxic mixes—from all branches
of the family tree.
For a long time, researchers focused
on only a small set of venomous animals: spiders,
snakes, scorpions, and some cone snails
— looking for new therapeutics and for clues to how
venom-victim pairs evolved.
How does venom change an animal's behavior?
Does the killer juice make you less afraid
of intimidating beasties?
And, why do some animals, like the assassin
bug, evolve two venoms--one for defending
itself and one for killing its prey?
The arms race between predator and resistant
prey has led to complex venoms that are incredibly
precise in their targeting, fast-acting, and
potent--all useful characteristics for medicines.
The toxins in venoms tend to either attack
the nervous system—paralyzing muscles, lungs,
sometimes blinding their prey
or they disrupt blood-coagulation—causing blood
to coagulate or preventing coagulation
--either can be deadly.
Such venoms have helped scientists understand
these systems themselves—a classic example
is using pufferfish venom to find a channel
important to nerve signaling.
The targeting ability of these venoms
and their strong effects on the body, have also
led to 6 venom-based drugs,
that have already been approved.
including a drug for diabetes
from the venom of the gila monster
and a painkiller derived from the venom
of the so-called magical cone snail.
Now, scientists are looking to these new sources
of venom --like the sea anemone-- to treat
autoimmune diseases and the deathstalker scorpion
for an entirely different use-- imaging brain tumors
during surgery.
Someday, scientists might just catch up
with these ancient chemists--but don’t count on it.